- Answers are cheap, right? We can
just say hey, Google how far is
Timbuktu from Kathmandu? - Timbuktu is 8,985
kilometers from Kathmandu as the crow flies.
- We just killed curiosity in that moment, right?
So, answers are cheap. Assumptions are really
dangerous, right? There's a time where somebody
reached out to see if I was available to speak
at an event, and they showed the acronym of their
conference and I looked it up, and it looked like,
it was going to be a bunch of FBI agents all
gathered in the same place. It turns out,
that was a different conference, and
they had the same acronym as one,
and I made the assumption. So, I hopped on
this call, and I did, my homework beforehand
and we're chatting, and it's like 10 minutes into
the conversation, I'm like, don't I did not expect
this from you. Turns out, it was an education
conference. Very different lens, very different
framing. The entire premise of my work and my
late co-authors' work around asking powerful
questions. When we ask powerful questions, we have
the ability to increase the psychological safety
that exists in an organization. Which research
would say is actually, the number one predictor
of high-performing teams. I would also say
that fear is the enemy of curiosity, right? So,
if you want an engaged organization, where
people are curious and taking initiative, and
accountability for what they want. You don't want
a lot of fear, and when we foster and encourage,
and build curiosity, it actually roots out fear.
When a group really understands deeply and is
practicing asking really great powerful questions,
it creates a learning organization and a learning
organization is one that doesn't die. The moment
that you or your organization stops learning,
is the moment that you start dying. Ukrainian
culture, where people are asking powerful
questions, and creating conversations that matter
also actually, fundamentally increases retention.
I was actually working with a group of 25
CEOs, once in a workshop in Philadelphia,
and all the same size company and they
didn't know this but I went and printed off,
hundreds of their reviews off of glassdoor, right?
The site that people go to. When they rage quit
and type in all caps about, how terrible your
organization is, or how great it is, or whatever
else. I had hundreds of these reviews printed
off, and for the workshop, I anonymized them. So,
nobody knew whose company they were talking about,
and I cut these out, and I had them placed on
tables all around the room, and their first tasks
when they walked in the room was. Hey, everybody,
I've printed out all of your glassdoor reviews.
Your goal is to sort these reviews into buckets
and chunks to try to figure out why do people stay
at your organizations and why do people leave, and
one of the things that was even surprising to me
that they found, is that 9 out of 10 reviews had
the word listen in them, or a synonym for it. So,
the model from our book Asked Powerful Questions
is designed to create this, right? To create an
organization, where people are willing to know
each other, they see each other, hear each other,
they really get each other, ultimately with each
other. Both from an internal perspective, and
from a customer client-facing perspective. Now,
the problem is if we've got a magic wand, we would
just wave it, and then, we'd create that. The
problem is that magic wand doesn't exist. Which
is why, will and I spent some time thinking about,
how to create it. And so, the flip side of
this pyramid is a series of skills, tools, and
mindsets, to help you foster a culture that looks
like this, and when you have a culture like that,
and people are asking questions that are rooted
in empathy, and rooted in their own curiosity. It
also tends to reduce implicit bias and Prejudice
in an organization. So, we have this desire to
create more inclusive cultures, where people feel
a sense of belonging. Those are really good words.
But as far as implementing them, we need practical
skills and tools to be able to practice that in
all the small moments of a 40-hour plus work week.
Just talking with a neuroscientist recently Eve,
Dr. Eve Miller, and she was saying
and echoing, and re-reminding me that,
how much our brains are actually wired our
amygdala, right? The part that fight or flight
is wired for belong, wired for connection. I
think instead of a fight-flight or freeze method,
our brains have actually adapted now in a modern
era for a fight-flight or a need to be liked,
or a need to be right in this culture. To
make a long story longer, I typically work
with organizations in three different levels
of how to ask powerful questions from coming in
and doing a kickoff keynote, really infusing this
culture, giving everybody an experience, and then,
following up with a guided journal materials Etc
or where we do a little bit more of a deep dive,
where I come do a kickoff, create an experience,
and all of this. But then remotely, or in person,
we have follow-ups diving deeper into each one of
these skills. Practicing that so, that the moment
they leave my session, they're actually using
the tools and the language that we experienced in
their next meeting, in their next one-to-one, etc,
and then, the third level that I tend to work with
people at is on a deeper ongoing context, where
we create a series of smaller group coaching labs.
Where we download all this content, experience all
this content, practice it. But come back every so
often to offset the curve of forgetfulness, and
talk about, okay. How is this really looking in
your organization? If this sounds interesting,
you want to bring some fun and positive,
and really practical professional development
to your own organization, School, University,
or event. Reach out, I would love to help convert
some of the exclamation points, and sentences that
end in periods, to sentences that end in question
marks in your organization. Have an awesome day.